hello freak [ __ ] just take time so
I'm going fountain I don't know how they
do it but they figured out splice things
change things and selectively breed
certain plants and they came up with
different strains that's why corn looks
the way it looks
old-school corn was like the size of a
hobos dick and it was it's all knotty
and [ __ ] up look it was like four
inches long tiny thing tastes the same
no I mean it's a hobos dick not all
those dicks weird man they're so
variable I never know what you get could
be a recent hobo like that guy who
punched you just old school snot blowing
veteran yes dick tastes like battery
acid okay yeah just the dick that's been
through the Pacific Southwest four guys
just doing that all day and he comes in
your mouth what do you think that - yeah
cuz I say that like a guy drinks orange
juice has come tastes better
yeah right have you heard that yeah
whenever I heard that I was like how
many dicks do you have to suck for you
figure that out you get away from me you
always with your [ __ ] scientist he's
sucking dick with a lab coat on taking
notes
hmm asparagus not recommended swishing
it around your mouth like you're a wine
connoisseur you always yells right of a
guy eats pineapples the guy eats
pineapples is can taste better right
but conversely if you just knew nothing
but smoking meth your loads have to
taste like hot death yeah and it does
and it's [ __ ] lumpy Oh pesticide yeah
loads taste like roundup it's not good
when you have to kill it it's not much
either things like a [ __ ] Hershey's
kiss swallow hit you in first [ __ ] first
no no [ __ ]
but then she's immediately trippin on
meth she's out of her mind do you
remember when that actor [ __ ] his name
Tom Sizemore
yeah when Time Sizemore went off the
rails yeah and did a porn yeah like they
would play
his his thing i Opie and Anthony all the
time because when he was coming he's
like Oh [ __ ] bah just a
cracked-out load there's nothing like a
crow like the sound of a man orgasm
where he knows he's just off the rail
yeah his off the rails on meth making a
porn it was in Saving Private Ryan here
he is oh that's as primal as it gets
it's like the pure heed being expressed
look at them just [ __ ] it can you play
it
no too little can't even show you this
illegal for you to play the audience
show this here's a madman he was a
madman wait how do you decide which
clips you're allowed to play at it on
that song yeah we can employ that get
away get away get her off get her off
get off get off the screen
yeah I'm just game I met him a long time
ago I did a show on vh1 called the list
yeah yeah remember that the host of it I
got to prime you were the host of the
list I was a hope one Elliott a growth
they've really related rotate okay so I
think I did two maybe three episodes but
one of them was I got to be Rob Halford
I got to meet Rick James James was a
Michael didn't do doesn't know kids he's
like we were talking about it and one of
the gals from Baywatch was on the show
as well and she was a mom god I can't
remember name a very very pretty girl
her name Mary to Nikki Sixx no I don't
think so remember which one she wore
anyway very nice girl Gina some more
another
anyway um she was it came up in some way
shape or form and she was like I don't
buy it I don't buy it he's like Michael
didn't do nothing I'm kids Michael
didn't do no name kids and that's all
[ __ ]
Mattel that's all [ __ ] and Rick
James had been up partying all night so
when he showed up like we were warned
that he might not be able to do it like
he got there and then you could tell he
just been up you know he's like mama I'm
suffering from some sort of a cold so if
I can't do this I can't do this and
we're like hey man do what you can do do
do but he went that point out there
plowed through like a trooper Wow yeah
but uh he was defending Michael Jackson
Michael didn't do nuttin but Michael
with his face
sighs mark came on and he had [ __ ]
slippers on he had like slippers and
[ __ ] bathrobe I don't remember what
he wore when he sat down but I remember
he showed up with slippers and a
bathrobe Wow he was just right when he
was just going off the rails Yeah right
when he was going it was supposed to be
him in Val Kilmer Val Kilmer was out
partying all night and then he was with
him and he just like Val Kilmer's like
[ __ ] I'm not going it's like laughs
Val Kilmer was gonna do the list yes Val
Kilmer was awful I don't remem when Val
Kilmer got huge fat and went crazy on
that's right he did a play I'm gonna
play for a while and it was like what
the [ __ ] is now come we're doing
partying yeah he was just going off I'm
just having fun
and it was during that time that
sizemore showed up he's a very nice guy
yeah super nice guy
mess huh I don't know what he was doing
he's doing a bunch of [ __ ] then he wound
up on Celebrity Rehab remember okay oh
that's right yeah
several seasons buzzing oh yeah oh
that's right he was almost Heidi Fleiss
like Heidi Fleiss was like his
girlfriend yeah that [ __ ] Celebrity
Rehab show could you imagine if you try
to do that today I know they don't do it
anymore now it's that you're exploiting
people it's the worst time you could
ever have someone in front of cameras
when they're their most vulnerable
yeah they are recovering from additional
you don't think that that's an
impediment to recovery putting them on
camera yeah following cameras around on
weather trying to detox and figure the
[ __ ] life out and you're giving a
massive amounts of attention you're
putting on shooting schedules you got
lob mics on them and they start having
affairs you encourage it when you're
supposed to discourage it it's crazy
it's everything that a a is not it's the
opposite of anonymous you're here Doug
Stanhope spit on it now Doug Stanhope
tortured dr. drew oh really
tortured him and he's a hundred percent
right yeah like some look they allowed
that show to happen dr. drew figured
like look I'm a competent doctor I'll
take care of it I'll make sure
everything's fine yeah at least it'll
expose lies it it'll expose to people
what it's like to you know go through
this and you see celebrities and movie
stars going through this but a lot of it
wasn't celebrities and movie stars it
was like sort of celebrities like Angie
Dickinson yeah where there's some guy in
the show with some young guy look at the
famous and brother
Oh Zeon Thanks I shouldn't say that
Julie Robert like down there across on
Lizzie and he was on 4 for pot whose
whole layouts God really helps all
[ __ ] up this dude he's got a newspaper
out he's drinking coffee good morning
everybody are gonna shake their I'll
[ __ ] themselves sweating through the
night he's like going through zero
withdrawal he's literally reading The
Times over a cup of coffee with his feet
up on the beach there is like Malibu
some hair and some serene environment
[Applause]
[Music]